hello and get ready for another exciting
episode of everything why don't we start
off by reading an email
this one's from Emily Murphy
she writes how excited are you about
moving into an actual house with Alex
cup of tea helps calm me down when I'm
feeling stressed out
I've been having lots of tea recently it
responds to your question Emily yes I am
extremely excited about moving into my
new house but I've a excited ever since
I asked to move into the house about
three months ago in the meantime I've
had to move back in with my mum and my
little sister which is completely fine
they're an absolute joy to be around
makes it most of the time now living in
bath isn't that much of a hassle but I
am very excited to move out so thank you
for your question
can I have some more tea we just ran out
of tea bags we just ran out of tea bags
that is what I just said we'll go to the
shop and get some more I sort of can't
because the shop is closed on Sundays so
you'll probably have to wait till
tomorrow get me some tea you you I don't
like living in bath I don't like my tiny
little bedroom I don't like the insanely
slow internet connection I don't like
not being able to see my friends
yo crap sticks my main man oh hey
Charlie is so cool hey how would you
like to come and visit me here in bath
absolutely not you live too far away
okay I don't like the fact that there's
nothing to do and I don't like the
feeling that I'm always being watched by
those creepy little toys that have been
placed all over the house
will that last one seriously about
cuddly toys yeah it sort of was you know
I guess there aren't as many bad things
about living here in bath as I
originally thought and I just found some
tea bags so do you want some tea and
stuff you know what I think I'm okay
everything is fine provided of course
that the solicitors don't push the house
move back another week right shut up and
go and make me some tea everything's
fine you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
this video featured a crabstickz
if you'd like to see some more of his
stuff click on that thingy over there
also if you'd like to see my previous
video just click on the pig that is on
my head